Don't hurt the child if you put one mark on him
there's no place you will be able to hide from me
welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my mandalorian season 2 episode 2 video
there were a whole bunch of easter eggs in the
episode so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything i'm doing videos for all the episodes
this season we're doing a disney plus giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite one favorite easter egg
from the episode on the video so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet we'll
do top 10 and easter eggs as we go along starting
with number 10 the title of the episode is the
passenger a reference to the frog lady in her
brood that she was trying to take to her husband
on the other planet the episode was actually
directed by peyton reed who directed the ant-man
marvel movies he's also directing ant-man 3 which
i believe is filming sometime next year there was
also a funny ant reference during the episode 2
giant and the person that was in the costume for
frog lady doing the creature performance was the
same person that did kuill's performance during
season one nick nolte just did the voice of kuill
but talking about some big avatar the last
airbender deep cuts d bradley baker did the voice
of frog lady now he's done hundreds and hundreds
of different voices he's been on pretty much all
the star wars tv series he's played clone wars
characters he's played star wars rebels characters
but the really cool avatar the last airbender deep
cut is that a lot of you might know that he was
actually the voice of appa that's right appa had
a voice the growls that he made that was d bradley
baker but there was also another appa in the
episode it was appa from kim's convenience i'll
explain his character when we get to that part
of the episode but the two appas from the episode
but number nine mando vs the bounty hunters at the
beginning of the episode it literally starts with
them still on tatooine heading back to the razer
crest right after the events of episode 1. so
a group of bounty hunters are up for baby yoda's
bounty or the child whatever you want to call him
it turns out that that's still active maf gideon
put a bounty on him they referenced at the end of
season one turns out that's still active that'll
be important for boba fett stuff later so remember
boba fett when you're thinking about the bounty
out for baby yoda they also try to remind you
about boba fett because we just saw him at the end
of episode one but they keep focusing the camera
on boba fett's helmet in his armor throughout that
first act of the episode i think just to remind
you that that's going to be a big thing later this
season also really big news there was a report
on deadline earlier today that the mandalorian
season 3 is going to start filming really soon and
they're supposed to start filming one of the new
mandalorian spin-offs that might wind up being a
boba fett miniseries so boba fett might be getting
his own tv show after the mandalorian season two
but you probably noticed that the little bounty
hunter here actually sounds a little bit like a
jawa so this might be a jawa bounty hunter but he
takes a knife to baby yoda bargains for mando's
jetpack and then they just have that funny moment
with him remote piloting it while baby yoda just
snorts at him you have to remember that he's 50
years old so he's actually way smarter than he
seems just because everyone assumes that he's
a baby because he coos like a baby all the time
a lot of you also asked why he doesn't speak it
is possible that he could speak and just chooses
not to we don't really know how old yoda was when
he started speaking too just because he ages so
slowly he'll still be a baby or seem like a baby
when the series eventually ends its run even if
it goes for seven to ten seasons which it probably
won't wind up going that long he would still look
exactly like this so dave filoni john favreau
probably won't ever have him speak any words
but then he has to lug it the rest of the way
across the desert with both sets of armor that's
gotta be pretty heavy but when he makes it to the
ridge and looks out over mos eisley it's meant
to mirror the scene of obi-wan kenobi looking
out over mos eisley talking to luke skywalker
you'll never find a more wretched hive of scum
and villainy and then they do the classic star
wars wipe transition from night to day he goes
back to the most iceland cantina the bartender
is still the ev-9d9 droid like the one from
jabba's palace this one remember was voiced
by mark hamill in season 1 in a very secret cameo
he doesn't speak in this episode but technically
it still is mark hamill's character the doctor
mandible alien that amy sedaris' character is
playing sabach with actually seems kind of like a
killik their ancestral home is actually alderaan
but that's been blown up because this is after
return of the jedi but because peyton reed from
the ant-man marvel movies directed the episode
and he's a giant ant i also felt it was kind
of like a reference to that because they could
literally put any aliens they want to in this bar
they go back to the hangar they finally roast
that crate dragon meat they use the treadwell
droid to do it from a new hope it's just one of
those other droids from the scene of the jawas
from the lars farm the same scene with r5 and
r5 is also with them throughout the episode too
they remind you that mando is also still looking
for the surviving members of his covert while he's
looking for other mandalorians that he hasn't
met before that could help him find other jedi
the number eight they introduced frog lady and her
eggs so frog lady's husband is the one who knows
where to find the other mandalorians and claims
that the planet that they're going to trask is
where those mandalorians are hiding out when they
mention they're going to the estuary moon of trask
in the system of the gas giant coal iben that's
not an area that's been featured in the star wars
universe before but they explain the reason that
they can't go to hyperspace is because her eggs
will die for some reason they can't exist inside
hyperspace but they also apparently can't exist
inside the razor crest in proximity to baby yoda
because he is absolutely fascinated with them like
they are the most delicious treat that he's ever
seen in his entire life when mando asks him later
how many of them he's eaten i think throughout
the episode he's snatched at least four or five of
those eggs he tries to communicate with her using
hud ease because that's such a common language
amongst traders bounty hunters smugglers merchants
in the area just because so much of this part of
space is controlled by the huts he also makes a
reference to pirates and warlords the warlord's
part is where we'll get to the moff gideon stuff
because technically maf gideon thinks of himself
as a moth still even though the empire doesn't
exist so technically there are no moths but
what's happened in the absence of the empire is
that there's still a lot of imperial resources in
ships and a lot of warlords all over the galaxy
have been racing to gather up all those resources
to make their fleet stronger mando takes baby
yoda puts him up in his tiny little hammock
and finally actually sleeps in that cargo hold
we've never actually seen him use it to sleep
before he's only used it just as a place to put
baby yoda and it's not very good at keeping him
inside because any time he walks off baby ota just
opens it right up and does whatever he feels like
but then number seven some big new republic cameos
mando's woken up by the proximity alarm after two
new republic x-wings get pissed that he's not
running a transponder those just emit the signal
identifying your vessel he's trying to be super
stealth so that no one will notice him so that's
why he's not running his but it's dave filoni
who's back again as one of the pilots his name
was trapper wolf because dave filoni loves wolves
in real life is also a call back to the loth wolf
from star wars rebels that he created he was one
of the x-wing pilots from season 1 episode 6 at
the end that took out those scoundrels the other
pilot in the episode you may recognize as appa the
other appa in the episode from kim's convenience
his character's name was captain carson teva but
in real life the actor there is actually a huge
star wars fan he cosplays at a lot of conventions
so that's probably how he wound up in the
episode i think he said that he got to visit
the set of the mandalorian during season 1 so
they probably saw that he was a huge fan of the
series and they just offered him a role during
season 2. mando says may the force be with you
one of the trademark star wars sayings from
all the movies in the tv series also a sign
that he's starting to embrace the concept of the
force in the jedi since he's been with baby yoda
a lot of people were wondering what this ice
planet was during the episode they never identify
but i believe it's meant to be crow nest which was
featured during star wars rebels remember we have
a lot of characters that are showing up from
star wars rebels in the clone wars this season
crow nest is where sabine wren's family had made
their home after they'd fled mandalore they chase
each other through the clouds the special effects
look gorgeous then as they head down to the trench
it actually looks a little bit like the way
they filmed the death star trench run as they
enter but there are a lot of different trench
runs of different types in the star wars movies
and in the video games too so you could pick your
reference here he manages to evade them but number
six winds up crash landing down into another ice
cavern even deeper damaging the ship almost beyond
repair the mother frog starts to freeze to death
in the cold because she's a warm blooded amphibian
she also starts to freak out about her eggs
mando almost tries to renege on their deal
and they have a bit of a moral in the episode too
that i'll talk about in a second because it's a
very clone wars trope of those episodes where they
had the moral at the beginning of all the episodes
they make a yoda empire strikes back joke about
the tiny rations like baby yoda just stares at
it like what the hell is this and then looks at
the tank of eggs like i would so much rather eat
one of those juicy eggs then number five they
bring back the zero droid from the same season
1 episode 6 like i said a lot of callbacks to
season 1 episode 6 with those group of scoundrels
the mother frog hacks the wreckage of the droid
zero who tried to kill baby yoda voiced by richard
ayotte he came back to do the voice again for this
episode very briefly he wasn't in the episode for
very long she uses his voice box to communicate
with mando and explain what's going on what's
at stake and sort of throw his honor in his face
i heard that mandalorians never go back on their
word and because he really does want to be this
honorable mandalorian and follow their code he
upholds their deal i think what they're doing here
is they're laying track work for mando versus boba
fett the quote unquote fake mandalorian who just
wears their armor but doesn't follow their code
but as he starts repairing the ship baby yoda
just sort of takes off and lets him know that
frog lady has also taken off but it turns out she
finds some hot springs i know a lot of people were
just wondering what was going on here when they
were walking through the ice caverns turns out
she's going for a quick dip in the hot tub with
her eggs i love that the child just keeps reaching
for the eggs at every possible opportunity every
time the mando turns around he has to almost slap
his hand away no don't touch him then he walks off
and finds a bunch of other eggs and just starts
clawing his way through them like it's the
greatest treat that he could possibly find he's so
happy with himself then you get the reveal of all
the tiny white spiders hatching out of their eggs
all over the place and even though they're in
this ice cavern and they kind of seem like ice
spiders they're actually white spiders from ralph
mcquarrie's original concept art here's the big
call back to yoda though because the spiders are
native to dagobah they were featured on star wars
rebels the clone wars luke even fought them during
his training they actually appeared for the first
time in that expanded universe novel the dark
saber then number four the great spider fight
so make all the game of thrones old nan jokes you
want about pale spiders biggest hounds i love that
frog lady jumps instead of runs i mean it kind
of makes sense if she is a frog mando disables
the mother spider with some charges uses his flame
thrower several times in the episode so remember
we're keeping track to see if the trend holds true
he used it in every single episode of season 1
and so far in season 2 now up through episode
2 that trend is held true the number three is
they claw their way into the cockpit barely
escaping the horde of spiders frog lady does baby
yoda a solid and takes the spiders out with some
cracked shots even though he's been poaching her
eggs left and right robbing her blind in number
two dave filoni to the rescue again so just as
the mother spider comes back and starts crushing
the ship the new republic pilots come and start
picking off all the spiders the funny thing here
is that they're cracked shots so they're picking
off these spiders in the ship from a long ways
away it's a bit of a callback to the joke about
the scout troopers the baby punchers from season
1 episode 8 played by jason sudeikis and adam pali
who were such terrible shots they couldn't hit the
ground if they fell down that's just part of the
long-running joke of star wars that storm troopers
all stormtroopers are terrible shots then they
explain to the mando that because he did so many
good things so many honorable things during season
1 episode 6 they're going to do him a solid and
not haul his ass in they make a reference about
all the bounties that he helped capture from the
wanted list those were the scoundrels like bill
burr's character and the other scoundrels from
that episode that he helped throw in that prison
ship and also how he stopped them from killing
lieutenant davin saving his life that was matt
lanter's character he was also a big celebrity
cameo because he's the voice of anakin skywalker
on the clone wars i didn't think that it was funny
that when he asked for their help in repairing the
razor crest they're like yeah thanks but no
thanks smell you later and they just take off
but number one like i said the quote-unquote clone
wars style moral of the episode so i think that
this whole episode all these moments here were
just a way to show you how even though at the time
doing the right thing the honorable thing almost
lost him baby yoda in the razor crest because the
scoundrels almost wound up killing him in the long
term upholding the mandalorian code his morals
doing the honorable thing karma comes back around
and helps him and i think it's all part of laying
the track work for his conflict with boba fett in
the idea of what makes a true mandalorian but they
patch things together enough to limp their way to
trask which i believe is the water planet with all
the quarren that we saw during the trailer because
you see frog lady with the tank on her back in the
trailer footage so i'm assuming that that's going
to be episode 3 next week but then they have that
funny little tag scene with baby yoda at the end
where he pulls that one last egg out like he just
stone cold i will eat every single one of your
children and enjoy it they are delicacies to me
it is funny to think of yoda's species as a group
of predators to that frog species but you have to
remember that he'll eat pretty much anything he
can get his hands on and we're talking about frog
references like him being a predator to the frog
species you have to remember that he tried to eat
an actual frog in season one episode four but if
there were any easter eggs in the episode that you
spotted that i didn't mention in the video just
write them below in the comments my mandalorian
season 2 episode 3 video will post next friday
just like normal also be doing more bonus videos
this weekend and next week so leave all your
requests in the comments below congratulations
to the giveaway winner from my last big star wars
video hang man please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my full mandalorian season
2 episode 1 video and click here to learn what's
happening with luke skywalker during the events
of the mandalorian season 2. thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!